[Musique]
salut québec
j'aimerais que vous fassiez tous des
points comme ça je vous vois tous mettez
les ensembles et regardez ce que ça
donne ça à peu près la grosseur de votre
cerveau de façon à peu près réaliste
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
neuroplasticité mais je vais commencer à
parler de la complexité du cerveau en
parlant de chiffres du plus petit au
plus grand 0,04 à 0,1 mm ça c'est le
diamètre d'un neurone celle à s'imaginer
ça donc voici un cheveu ou du moins une
représentation d'un cheveu et voici un
neurone à côté donc prévoir vraiment la
différence de diamètre entre un cheveu
et un neurone 1,3 1,4 kg
c'est le poids du cerveau ce soit quand
de les retourner chez vous à l'épreuve
peut-être parler des conférences autour
d'une bonne bouteille de vin prenait la
bouteille de vin paisible à un peu et
bien sûr une bouteille de vin plein qui
pèse 3.4 kg 4 à 6 minutes
ça c'est le nombre de temps qui s
apprend au cerveau a commencé à mourir
après manqué d'oxygène donc c'est pas
très très long 10 à 40 watts c'est la
capacité de cerveau c'est la puissance
générée par le cerveau au repos s'est
tassée soit pour allumer une ampoule ou
même allumé un néon 20% d'oxygène
ça c'est la capacité totale du cerveau
de l'oxygène utilisé par le cerveau est
assez impressionnant parce que si on
compare tous les systèmes du corps
humain à ce bloc appartement vous allez
voir que le cerveau représentent 2 % de
total du corps humain mais utilise 20 %
de leur capacité à nos jeunes n'y a pas
de réserve d'oxygène au niveau du
cerveau mais là 10000 ça c'est le nombre
de connexions le nombre de synapses pour
chaque neurone qu'on a dans le cerveau
si on compare les neurones à des
autoroutes ou des routes pour chaque
route il y aurait environ 1000 à 10000
qui viendrait se connecter dessus on va
voir tout alors il ya combien de
neurones vous allez voir ça c'est
impressionnant
cent soixante mille kilomètres c'est le
nombre de kilomètres du réseau sanguin
dans le cerveau
donc le nombre de kilomètres de
vaisseaux sanguins ça c'est à s'y faire
quatre fois le tour de la terre où
environ un demi lune demi fois la
distance entre la terre et la lune
donc si vous mettez deux personnes
ensemble vous pouvez rejoindre la lune
avec votre réseau vasculaire et là on
arrive d'aller dans les grosses dans les
gros chif
soixante dix milliards soixante dix
milliards ça c'est les cellules gliales
qu'on a dans le cerveau les cellules
gliales c'est le fixatif des neurones
c'est ce qui amène une structure
gélatineuse au cerveau un peu comme les
petits bonbons jello conte ici et 85 à
100 milliards de neurones c'est le
nombre de neurones qu'on a à la
naissance
donc si vous rappeler tout à l'heure la
grosseur de votre cerveau avec une
complexité
un homme comme ceux ci 100 milliards de
neurones multiplié par le nombre de
connexions de synapses 1000 à 10000 ça
fait une complexité assez importante sur
ces des neurones a grandi au microscope
c'est magnifique c'est quoi la
neuroplasticité c'est la capacité du
cerveau à se mobiliser à ce module est à
changer sa structure
j'ai fait une analogie si donc les
neurones c'est comme des chemins
ils vont faire un chemin de a à b pour
effectuer une fonction et donc on va
avoir une transmission d'énergie comme
ici un petit garçon qui va le terrain de
soccer
il va faire son chemin une journée va
avoir un traumatisme ou ici un arrêt de
construction d'un allah vote qui va
l'empêcher de francs ce chemin là le
cerveau va falloir qu'ils se
réorganisent pour trouver un autre
chemin
donc on va trouver notre chemin se voir
le chemin beaucoup plus petit il est
moins imprégné s'émousser pas le chemin
habituel et la force de refaire le
chemin le chemin ce grossit et l'ancien
chemin disparaît
on connaît bien la neuroplasticité chez
les enfants parce que au cours de la
croissance
le cerveau va se développer et donc la
neuroplasticité très connu chez des
enfants donc je n'en parlais pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui
reibel à l'abstrait ce que j'ai pris en
photo au népal lors de mes voyages
donc la neuro place c'est chez l'enfant
est modulé par le développement guidé
par les expériences
on voit ici d'apprentissage à marcher
par exemple ou à toucher des structures
différentes textures et ainsi de suite
chez l'adulte maintenant en 1913
santiago damon qui était un grand
novateur anatomiste a dit les neurones
sont immuables
arrivé à l'âge adulte et la seule chose
qui peut se produire c'est que les
neurones vont mourir on va voir
aujourd'hui que c'est plus vraiment
actuelle elle est belle hein c'est ma
femme
[Applaudissements]
il ya des chercheurs anglais qui ont une
bonne idée on dit on va regarder le
cerveau des chauffeurs de taxi conduire
à londres c'est très difficile c'est
très intense donc en 1997
les chercheurs sont allés voir est ce
que les cerveaux des chauffeurs de taxi
sont différents de monsieur madame tout
le monde puisqu'ils ont trouvé c'est
assez intéressant et ont trouvé qu'une
partie du cerveau était plus volumineux
mais la matière grise et dans
l'hippocampe
ça s'est associé à la navigation
spatiale et ils se sont dit est ce que
ces gens là sont des chauffeurs de taxi
parce qu'ils ont des structures plus
développé leur cerveau ou leurs
structures sont plus développés parce
qu'ils sont des chauffeurs de taxi donc
ils ont fait la même étudiants sont
allés voir les chauffeurs d'autobus
allons donc la différence entre un
chauffeur d'autobus et un chauffeur de
taxi c'est que le chauffeur d'autobus va
faire toujours le même trajet ou presque
alors quel chauffeur de taxi son trajet
est modulé selon la personne qui va
venir dans son taxi
ils se sont rendus compte que en effet
chez les chauffeurs de taxi leur matière
grise était plus volumineuse et se sont
dit on va regarder quand les gens
commencent à faire leur apprentissage de
leur chauffeur de leur licence de taxi
est ce que une modulation est ce que la
matière grise va changer puis c'est en
effet le cas donc c'est une des
premières preuves qu'on a eu au niveau
de la neuroplasticité avait des
changements structurels au cours de
l'apprentissage des licences de taxi
pour être chauffeur de taxi à londres
c'est environ deux ans d'apprentissage
donc c'est assez énorme
d'autres et une autre étude qui nous a
montré la neuroplasticité chez l'adulte
c'est des chercheurs suisses en 2012
qu'on fait une étude avec
l'apprentissage d'une langue seconde
donc ils ont mis des des jeunes adultes
en apprentissage pendant cinq mois d'une
langue qu'il ne connaissait absolument
pas et ils ont mesuré les différentes
structures au niveau du cerveau puis
s'est rendu compte que la matière grise
aussi était augmenté suite à
l'apprentissage et de plus ils ont
corrélés le fait que plus
l'apprentissage était efficace ou plus
la compréhension était bonne suite à cet
apprentissage long plus la matière grise
était développé notamment au niveau du
gyrus frontal qui est au niveau 2 du
langage et de la compréhension des
langages donc une autre forme de neuro
place et qu'on a pu mesurer chez nos
personnes âgées chez les personnes âgées
est ce qu'on peut avoir un changement
structurel au niveau du cerveau on
passait auparavant que avec le
vieillissement les neurones allait
mourir et qu'il pouvait pas vraiment
avoir de changements structurels chez
les personnes âgées il ya des chercheurs
allemands ont trouvé une étude assez
intéressante
qu'est ce qu'on préfère faire à des
personnes âgées pour voir si leur
cerveau va s'améliorer ils auront fait
refaire de la jonglerie trois mois
d'entraînement intensif et ont mesuré le
cerveau différentes structures du
cerveau avant l'avant d'entraînement de
jonglerie et trois mois plus tard ils
ont re mesurer ces structures là ils ont
trouvé deux choses au niveau de
l'hippocampe
on avait une augmentation structurelle
au niveau du cerveau saussez au niveau
de la mémoire ce travail au niveau de la
mémoire est aussi de la navigation
spatiale et au niveau du noyau accumbens
et ça c'est assez intéressant
le noyau accumbens et ce qui constitue
le maillon central de la récompense
n'est pas juste ça donc pour les
personnes âgées jongler cellphone
c'était comme la récompense mais c'est
une des structures qui les plus
impliqués dans les dépendances aux
drogues et ont poussé les tirades peu
plus loin on dit maintenant qu'on a fait
c'est entraînant là pendant trois mois
on va les arrêter complètement de faire
l'entraînement
arrêtez de faire de l'argent de leur
reer ou un mois plus tard ils ont remis
jurés les structures du cerveau et se
sont rendus compte que les structures
avaient régressé donc en europe la cité
oui c'est intéressant mais ça fonctionne
dans les deux sens ce qu'on fait vont
influencer la structure du cerveau mais
ce qu'on ne fait pas aussi voit
l'influencé
pour ma part je m'intéresse beaucoup aux
populations symptomatique pathologique
ça c'est la photo de jodi petite fille
qui avait un syndrome de rasmussen
jean d'épilepsie et sur ce syndrome n'a
fait que quand on se promène ou à peu
près à n'importe qui peut avoir des
crises qui faisaient que la petite fille
perdait connaissance
tomber sur le côté donc très difficile
de fonctionner ce que les chirurgiens
ont fait ils ont enlevé la moitié du
cerveau vous avez la photo ici ce qui
est noir c'est du liquide le reste des
cerveaux donc le cette petite fille là
fonctionne avec un demi cerveau quand
elle se réveillait de la chirurgie elle
était paralysé d'un côté du côté opposé
à laquelle les mystères avait été
enlevée mais ça a pris dix jours avant
que la petite fille se remettre à
marcher et même à courir du jour une
incroyable placé cérébrale s'est
produite
et si vous verrez la petite fille
aujourd'hui qui a 12 ans vous ne ferait
même pas la différence
à savoir qu'elle a seulement 1 2 me soit
pour ma part je travaille plus avec les
traumatisés crâniens légers
je travaille avec les commotions
cérébrales vous avez une image ici d'une
imagerie cérébrale que j'ai collaboré
avec l'université de toronto
on voit pas très bien sur image mais il
ya des hommes qui sont activés quand on
va faire des double tâche je travaille
beaucoup en double tâche est donc qu'on
a développé une approche pour favoriser
la neuroplasticité avec différents
facteurs dont en utilisant la double
tâche on a ici un vidéo du laboratoire
vous allez voir des fois on pense que
c'est bien compliqué cerveau on utilise
des moyens du bord et qu'on a pour faire
des expériences ici la vidéo va passer
très vite donc je veux juste vous portez
votre attention vous voyez la jeune
fille sur le tapis en haut du tapis
roulant il ya un écran un écran qui
projette des mots en couleurs la
personne focalise les mauves k10 des
couleurs et bien sûr l'émotion dans une
couleur différente
elle marche sur le tapis roulant et en
même temps qu'elle marche et qu'elle dit
les mots un moment donné sans qu'on
sache quand le la barre jaune qui est à
bord c'est un obstacle qui va se
déplacer et la personne faut qu'ils
passent par dessus
aussi mon étudiant à la maîtrise et sauf
et sort avec des personnes qui ont des
commotions cérébrales
pour deux raisons pour tester leur
altération fonctionnel pour voir jusqu'à
quel niveau elles vont avoir de la
difficulté à faire la tâche bien sûr ils
risquent de favoriser l' équilibre aux
dépens des réponses
il y en a qui vont favoriser les
réponses et vont avoir des cheveux et on
transfère sa du laboratoire en clinique
donc en clinique on va travailler avec
des patients qui ont des commotions
cérébrales on va être réduit le concept
de double tâche ont reçu favoriser la
plasticité avec trois principes que je
vais vous parler que vous allez pouvoir
prendre à la maison favoriser votre
propre placé dans quelques minutes et on
va travailler aussi des exercices
d'équilibré comme ici sur cette impasse
en très très très docile c'est mon fils
est donc on fait des exercices comme ça
en faisant soi des calculs mathématiques
ou des fois on va faire des projections
sur les murs avec des mots de couleur
différent donc vous qui êtes si vous
êtes probablement tous sains d'esprit et
centre matisse l'espoir qu'est-ce que
vous prédisez comme principe pour
favoriser une bonne neuroplasticité il
ya plusieurs facteurs génie ciblé trois
qui sont faciles à utiliser que vous
pouvez prendre à partir de tout de suite
et mettre en application le premier
concept c'est être actif physiquement
être actif aussi cognitive mentalement
ne jamais cessé d'apprendre des choses
nouvelles
ça c'est la base en étant actif on va
favoriser la vascularisation du cerveau
on va favoriser une bonne nouveaux plats
cités pour favoriser la neuroplasticité
faut que les patients soyez engagé des
gardes les patients qui viennent nous
voir qu'ils veulent qu'on fasse un
traitement cinq sont engagés ça
fonctionnera pas faut que le patient
s'engage à faire des exercices
même si des fois de certains exercices
peuvent amener des symptômes deuxième
principe
c'est le sommeil faut avoir une bonne
hygiène de sommeil sas et un sommeil
réparateur qui va aider beaucoup la
neuroplasticité puis des fois on va même
travaillé au niveau de micro pause dans
la journée pour favoriser du repos et
favoriser la neuroplasticité et le
troisième aspect qui que j'ai choisi lui
qui fait partie vraiment la neuropathie
c'est qui peut vous paraître peut-être
un petit peu plus spécial c'est de
participer à des activités sociales
comme vous êtes en train de faire
aujourd'hui quand vous allez à aller au
cocktail tout à l'heure donc ces trois
aspects lors on vous permettre de
favoriser une bonne rampe la cité je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de traumatismes
que ce soit un traumatisme physique qui
va avoir des altérations au niveau du
cerveau ou du traumatisme psychique qui
ne peut pas être aidés avec des
principes de neuroplasticité donc ce que
je vous demanderai de faire tout le
monde levez-vous
c'est la seule manière que je peux avoir
une ovation debout
et est ce que je veux que fassiez serrer
la main de votre voisin fait que ça
c'est la première étape de la
neuroplasticité deuxième étape
deuxième étape au cocktail on parle on
retourne à pied à la maison bois ou du
moins ou du moins jusqu'à votre voiture
et ce soir ayez un bon repos merci
[Applaudissements]